action podcast do you see an action 3
you're listening to the dollop on the
all things comedy Network this is a
bilingual American history podcast where
each week I see my friend Gareth
Reynolds who has no idea what the topic
is going to be about what happened there
you left the pregnant pause we're here
we're gonna go through your dumb three
occupation or you got pretty excited at
this point I do enjoy this version more
I'm not sure if it's gonna happen it's
not it's better so I wanted to make an
announcement we are going to the dollop
is now going to be in Spanish we is a
bilingual it is literally a bilingual
history podcast show to two gentlemen
who are from Mexico they have a podcast
called
layin bass legend arias el podcast they
I'm trying to this was great it's in
Spanish I was trying to pull it I
thought this is a bilingual no problem
dammit
adios mio it's all in Spanish okay so
anyway so uh so they have this great
podcast in in Mexico it's very popular
and they're also fans of the doll so
they will be doing the they will be
taking our scripts translating them and
they'll be doing a el dollop a version
of the doll in Spanish so if you have
spanish-speaking friends or you know
anybody who's spanish-speaking you want
a great way to learn Spanish yeah a
great way to learn Spanish so if you
want to introduce them to the dollop
this is a great way to do that the hosts
are Jose Antonio Padilla and Eduardo
Espinoza and they're really funny guys
they're like uh still left guys and
they're great so that should start
that should start a centrist I think
this week or maybe Monday but that's
when the first ones going to drop will
probably drop the first episode on our
feed it'll be totally in Spanish so you
can just give it to your tell your
friends about it or whatever from people
out who haven't heard this part I'll do
an intro so they know it's okay but
there you go the dogs gonna be in
Spanish but yeah it's fun yeah it's
great yeah I still don't care for you
okay I mean I don't know why what the
link is called the quote I'm putting is
jam-packed okay this is not gonna come
sick arguments
that's some good stuff so now I'm now
I'm really gonna learn spam that's some
good stuff what what happened I the
intro
very good there you enjoy Arya Arya I
loved it it's a ride what's happening
right now it's a ride do you have some
dates coming up that you want to ride
buddy it's a fun rocks going on right
now it's a fun ride don't say that if
you want to watch this dynamic feed of
us doing the podcast you can go to the
all things comedy YouTube page and you
can watch us do the podcast and let me
tell you from looking and monitor right
now hey look crazy David I will be at
the Denver improv April 24th through the
26th I will be at the Pittsburgh improv
April 30th through May 3rd I will be
I'll be at stand-up in Phoenix Arizona
at CB what is that right you know you're
really good at this
mmm CB live oh that is right okay I'll
beat CB live Thank You Aaron [ __ ] you
Dave and I'll be a directly improv in
North Carolina May 28th through the main
gates first and then there's even some
June ones I'll be in Dallas in June just
go to Gareth Rhodes that cop some of the
tickets aren't up you have to ask Aaron
what the club is named eat what's great
is like a rap duo I didn't even need to
ask him he just [ __ ] jumped in and
filled in the gap so just so you know
that was like the rap duo of Chuck D and
Flavor Flav that's how bad that was
today well certain Lauder and Darren was
Flav of Aaron you were for sure Flav you
know your Flavor Flav that's rude we the
dollop will be G duck with the dog we'll
be doing a show this week Royal Oak
Michigan on March 6 Minneapolis on March
7th our guests will be Bill Corbett who
is very very very funny I always wanted
him on and
adorable and adorable and then now we
will be in the next week two weeks
Cincinnati Pittsburgh and Cleveland and
then we do Seattle and Portland later in
March then we're in Houston Austin
Dallas Oklahoma City Nashville st. Louis
Kansas City Des Moines West Palm Beach
tampa orlando louisville indianapolis
hey West Palm Beach what do you say you
aren't the worst selling show ever
uh let's counter with a better offer you
buy one ticket you get 55 for free hurry
up
also my friend Kyle burns is in
quarantine
oh he cook yet yes he is Lawrence in
quarantine no burns his brother Kyle the
other burns he is in quarantine how how
did he get questioned oh he's a crew why
why would you know the crews worked on
it he worked on the cruise ship on you
he's the big one the one that everyone
talks about he's on that one yes and
he's still in quarantine and all he's
doing is listening to podcast and he's
been listening to the lot of the dollar
and so I told him we would shout him out
I have said it is mind-numbing ly boring
oh I can imagine but I have a policy
never ever ever go on a cruise ship for
work or for enjoyment never ever going
to Christian the only loophole go there
for crabs okay not the animal ones okay
crabs are good yeah you can get those so
easily which kind of crabs are we
talking about she scratches why would
you want those doesn't everybody want to
be some sort of culture no oh I don't
think so I think up to me it's fun to be
I like having a bunch of different like
species on me I sort of feel like my own
earth so you feel like you want to be a
host I love the idea of being a host
thank you know me I love to host parties
yeah I love my body to be a host okay
that's why I have tapeworms I have tons
of tons of things but I'm looking I'm
excited to go on I'm going on a cruise
next week to hopefully hopefully fine
yeah I picture like the under the sea
kind except you know they're under
you're like they do under the pubes on
to the pubes on to the pubes you know
darling it's better down where it's
wetter under the pubes
on Aaron you with me who's with no one
is with you
let's try to change the subject because
this is really upsetting so we are
brought to you in part by a native of
course is a situation natives the other
and is made without aluminum so you can
feel better about what you're putting on
your body I have not used aluminum
deodorant in a long time I switch to
native look people are like it's not
gonna work its natural it works natural
deodorants work yeah they just do and
aluminum is terrible aluminum is
terrible yeah it really why would you
wanna put aluminum right you're a little
poor oh yeah get in there buddy swim
around NATO Jota is formulated without
aluminum parabens or talc it's also
vegan and never tested on animals very
important why would you test the odorant
on animals it's got ingredients you know
like coconut oil and shea butter you
wear deodorant every day you should be
able to know what's in it you're putting
it on your body they have a great sense
I use to I use eucalyptus and mint and
then I also use cucumber mint I'm a big
mint under the pit guy that's just how
I'm rolling you do Pitman's pitman yeah
yeah what do you have are you yeah the
coconut or the coca yeah I don't like
I'm not a coconut I don't like coconut
the smell I don't like the way it tastes
well I'll tell you as a coconut person
we don't like you okay okay that's fine
I don't like you either
look there's no risk to no risk to try
free shipping on every order and native
offers 30-day free returns and exchanges
in the US they also have a toothpaste
now too minty flavors it's all happening
over there doesn't your so I use it it
smells good I don't I don't you know
it's it's different it works what else
is there to say like native makes sense
that's right so don't do that
for 20% off your first purchase visit
native deodorant calm and use promo code
dollop during checkout 20% off your
first purchase visit native deodorant
calm and use promo code dollop during
checkout though you like that yeah I
like you
what thank you a lot we are also brought
to you by ritual which of course a
vitamin situation
catch Schneider and her team of
scientists came up with this way to make
clinically-tested a new normal they're
there to know what's inside your vitam
that's right know it's inside your
vitamin transparency have it all nice
it's it's you know they left out all the
mystery additives that they have another
I'm just gonna make a list of that stuff
that's and other other vitamins that you
don't know about because there's no
transparency horse hair human eyes figs
horse horse poop
whole cats what well until then I was in
but none of that's happening at ritual
because ritual tells you what is in
every single vitamin it's called
traceability my wife is he is using it
the the ritual for the ladies
she's teetering nauseous and that's why
she stopped taking vitamins and they
have this anti nausea thing so she takes
it she doesn't get nauseous at all much
is a huge that's a big that's always
been a big drawback for vitamins for me
yeah yeah we've all taken we've all done
that single an accident when you take
vitamins on an empty so my god too drunk
at a party so ritual is designed to be
gentle on an empty stomach their delayed
release no nausea design capsule is made
to be gentle on an empty stomach and the
mint essence tab and every bottle makes
taking your vitamins a minty fresh
experience so look daily changes can
lead to big results so start small today
rituals offering our listeners 10% off
your first three months try it out
satisfaction guaranteed go to ritual
calm slash dollop to start your ritual
today that's ten percent off during your
first three months at ritual calm slash
dollop and of course we were also
brought to you by policy genius look if
there's one thing humans aren't great at
its predicting the future except for me
I'm really good at it
but just take a look around you know no
amount of crystal balls fortune cookies
or tea leaves can predict the world
we're living in right now right
well well some fortune cookie but
unpredictably is also unpredictability
is also what keeps life interesting the
trick is to enjoy the ride without
worrying about what's around the corner
and one way to worry less is to protect
the things you work so hard for like
your home which means you need home
insurance which means you should try
policy genius
first head deposit juice calm and answer
a few questions about yourself and your
property then pause the genius will
compare your policy against options from
top insurers to make sure you're getting
the right home insurance coverage at the
best possible price they've saved their
customers an average of six hundred
ninety dollars per year doing just that
and if policy genius finds you a better
rate than what you're currently paying
they'll do all the work to get you
switched you own a car policy genius
will compare your home and auto policies
across different insurers and even makes
a match to find your savings it this
makes it so much easier than having to
do it all yourself called Randy blah
blabbity blah right this is the way to
do it this is what I did drain line yeah
it just makes they do the work you just
put in what you want it's beautiful so
if you haven't found the if you so if
you haven't found a play-by-play
breakdown over your future inside a
crystal ball or a cookie that's ok
protect the things you've worked hard
for and get home insurance with policies
genius it's just a few minutes in just a
few minutes you can find your best price
and apply at policy genius calm policy
genius we always get the future wrong a
better get home insurance right
and finally zip recruiter yep yeah you
know what I'm talking about the staple
gear core you you are about to get fired
so this is a probably this is something
you probably listen ok that's what
happens and I put podcast host in there
like the interview podcast
according to zipper could of research
nearly three-quarters of employers say
they're finding it difficult to fill
open positions example of the bolt steps
they're taking a higher 68% of employers
have raised their wages
well 23 percent have increased their
benefits yeah take that up to 50 come on
if you have a difficult role to fill no
matter what your industry hire was zip
recruiter and now you can try zip
recruiter for free at zipper greater
comm slash dollop we of course you
always looking for cat lifters here at
jerk or yes and hands-on cat all hands
on cat and then we need a feeder we call
it we call you paw bears oh yeah we had
a few a six six people we had a feeder
shoes feeding and her name is Bridget
she lost an arm yeah so but to be fair
she didn't toss the kibble she tried to
hand it that's true which is clearly
stated in the contract yeah he's not in
a way you don't feed him like no god no
and don't turn your back that's right
ever
zip recruiter sends your job to over a
hundred job sites but they don't stop
there with their powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans thousands
of resumes to find people with the right
skills and experience for your job and
actively invites them to apply you can
even add screening questions to your job
listing so you can filter candidates and
focus on the best one zipper crit are so
effective that four to five employers
who post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day so try to
try super critter for free my my
listeners yours ours can go to zip
recruiter comm slash dollop that zip
recruiter com a slash do llo p zip
recruiter comm slash dollop zip
recruiter the smartest way they hire
yeah yeah do I know you
yeah yeah you know me I don't yeah you
do I feel like I did at one point and
then he lost it yeah I felt like I feel
like I've never known you more June 23rd
1948 a year of our Lord Jesus Christ Day
Clarence Thomas was your sweet little
face oh dear oh boy
alright yeah we're on one Clarence
Thomas was born in pinpoint Georgia in a
mostly black community near Savannah he
was the second of three kids
his father bailed on the family early
and his mother Leola erased them they
lived in poverty okay there was no
sewage system or paved roads
his mother worked as a maid and took
charity from the church to get by and
Wow okay
very humbling beginnings yeah when
Christ was seven their house burned down
I don't know how but you know that's
just par for the course right this is
what happens yeah and then his mom
decided to get married so she sent
Clarence Ins brother to live with his
grandfather in Savannah
okay so one of those I'm getting married
let's just completely start over right
without the children the children yeah
she kept the girl which is weird
well I get it this was a much better
life
he had regular meals and indoor plumbing
Wow [ __ ] in the regular meals
[ __ ] in the house now there we go
eating eating three times a day and then
also being on your home yeah yeah
the boys worked for their grandfather
making deliveries
Clarence's grandfather urged him to
become a priest okay wish he'd followed
the path yeah so Clarence left his
all-black high school after two years to
go to Saint John Vianney minor seminary
which was an all-white boarding school
that trained priests so he went to an
all-white boarding school yeah that's
but it's but they're training priests so
you would think that it would be I mean
you know you're you're a religious man
you're all learning how to become
priests you would think there's an
open-mindedness yeah you would be yeah
the Lord's love is great the Lord's love
knows no bounds unless of course you're
not white then it's like half as much
yeah they're not good then he likes you
a little bit yeah you're bumming the
Lord out by being in an all-white school
you see Clarence you made the choice to
be non-white that was your first mistake
being black Clarence was excluded from
social activities and made fun of for
his skin classics like classic Prix
stuff yeah
but he's stuck in there and he graduated
with decent grades after he went to the
Immaculate Conception Seminary in
Missouri
well let me pretty straightforward
curriculum conception you owe the I see
you yeah I see yes [ __ ] yeah I served in
seminary I'm sorry that's so close you
almost did it yeah it's close he didn't
finish he quickly dropped the the church
likes when you don't finish yeah it's
just big on I'm not even starting helps
so I'm gonna pull out great time great
go ahead and come on my face actually
well that's how it ended up Mary that's
that's why they consider it a man
the conception because Mary was like no
pull out you know so they were like he
didn't yeah they don't go over that part
in the Bible because the holy skim it
matters a whole pullout thing that's all
there was also just the tip part there's
a lot of then Lord I should just try the
tip potentially yes use just the helmet
part all right lord I will okay Lord I'm
just Oh God leave the part of the Moses
Oh God Lord no I'm tired sleep in-law
you're smoking Pall Mall yes good Lord
good me so he bails because the racism
is so bad and he went to Holy Cross
there he helped form the Black Student
Union and supported the Black Panthers
interesting Wow Wow yeah what happens
the system you're just like the devil
must work in DC somewhere it's he just
has never layer come before word
Clarence
in 1971 clance graduated ninth in his
class with a English honors degree the
next day he married Cathy ambushed
last night yeah well not a lot of people
know this he didn't even know they were
getting married he just thought he was
going to a regular ceremony Cathy job
dad she's like can't the ambush we'll
get married
music clance was then accepted to Yale
Law School through its affirmative
action program okay
while he was at Yale they had a son
Jamal and when he graduated a lot of
firms tried to recruit him they told him
he could do pro bono work which offended
him oh yeah they like we are black guys
you want to work here yeah okay instead
he took a job in Missouri with State
Attorney General John Dan
earth Republican sure he worked in the
tax division and didn't have to go near
any civil rights cases which he didn't
want to do he he had an aversion to
civil right cases yeah okay
Danforth was elected to the Senate in
1977 and Clarence became a corporate
lawyer in the pesticide and agriculture
division of the amounts Santo company
just happened so fast sensitivity for
the lack of indoor plumbing and now he's
a lawyer for a lobbyist for pesticides I
mean something definitely yeah Yael
something definitely have any Gale well
what happens at Yale yeah for sure
number one he got into the affirmative
action program which he was probably
bitter about or God took heat for mad
about probably but who knows you just go
you know what I just want money so much
that I will do whatever ya mean Monsanto
is an abysmal abysmal organization yeah
they really are
after two years he went to work for
Danforth as a legislative aide in
Washington in 1980 he went to a black
conservatives conference and The
Washington Post published an article
about him now he's getting a little
attention this happens too yeah cuz
they're like they're like we found a
unicorn like a black conservative I
gotta write that up well I would you can
even honestly trace that that sensation
bat like if you if you're him and you go
through the like that seminary program
and things like that you're the only
black guy you're treated differently to
now you go into environment where your
race actually makes you something
elevates you yes I mean that's you know
I well well you know [ __ ] that that
group of gentlemen still like you can't
I guess you can kind of understand the
psychology behind it a little bit you
know yeah I guess I guess Malcolm X had
a name for people like where's Thomas oh
so the article gets him attention from
the Reagan administration good and then
they offered him a job as the assistant
secretary for civil rights in the
education okay well and and can I just
jump in again and say that knowing
Reagan's track record with civil rights
obviously he had a big I don't print I
don't think we've ever ID a president
that did more for civil rights than
Ronald yeah I agree
hundred percent Clarence Chuck the job
soon he was promoted to head of the
Equal Employment Opportunity Commission
the EEOC where he supervised federal
efforts to curb discrimination in the
workplace there's gonna be a problem
looking down the river further I see
some rocky areas and some conflict ahead
so Clarence and said a lot of companies
to be more flexible with hiring
minorities okay he ended the use of
class action suits that relied on
statistical evidence of discriminatory
effects so he basically logical cases
were no longer aligned like no more
stats today prove you know as the point
stats will prove your point yeah
absolutely every stats right civil
rights groups were furious when he did
this now I need a hill was born on July
30th 1956 in lonetree Oklahoma she was
the youngest of 13 children Wow
that's [ __ ] crazy yeah she went to
Oklahoma State University and then Yale
Law School and after being admitted to
the bar 1980 she worked at a Washington
DC law firm and then 1981 was hired as
an attorney advisor to Clarence Thomas
in the Office of Civil Rights uh-huh
they're working with a ship was a good
it was good at first quote I thought
that he respected my work and that he
trusted my judgment but after three
months he asked her to go out with him
she declined saying it would jeopardize
their good working relationship also
he's married yeah I was gonna ask he's
married so what yeah the comfort the
yeah even okay if you're cheating mm-hmm
don't you just feel a tremendous sense
of guilt aren't you always hiding it no
instead you're at work David
Oh
but instead you're at work like come on
date me I don't know how yeah yeah I
mean apart mentalize it yeah that's
right I I've never understood like like
cheating to me like you're I can fight
cheat on my wife I feel horrible but
then on top of that just doing it at
work or like people you that are all
around your old yeah it's just crazy
yeah I bet it'd be clearly it turned
crazy
it's a terrible decision yeah so she
declined saying would jeopardize their
good working relationship and you're
married also she was very uncomfortable
with the idea of dating him and she
explained that to him clearly she
thought that would end it it did not he
kept asking her out and he asked her to
justify why she was saying no which is
first of all by the way that's a cool
that you come off cool when you do that
yeah you do
why look at me I'm [ __ ] awesome hey
does this follow-up validate you in any
way why you notice I've kind of look
like a square why this always happened
when they were alone Clarence then
started using the times they had to be
together at work to talk about sex he
started calling her into his office and
then discussing things of a sexual
nature quote his conversations were very
vivid he talked about different sex
scenes he had seen important movies whoa
that's just how you bet I never hit on a
woman that's how you do it you might
miss out actually by her next monkey
what do you do for work I am an attorney
you know I was watching a porno this
morning what where it was a couple of
attorneys and one of the prosecuting
attorneys bent the defense attorney over
the bench and the stigma or started
kissing the price it was a very hot sex
and I watched and I watched it for ages
I love porno so sometime would you maybe
want to go camping
no maybe no no no no I've been watching
a lot of good camping porn la that makes
me less want to go camping with you does
that make sense there was uh well I just
if I may and
for a moment I was watching a porno
about a week week and a half ago call
some pornos I was watching a camping
porno and it was basically this couple
was worried that there was going to be a
bear and they lost some of their
supplies and then they were cold so they
decided to sleep next to each other for
warmth yeah well of course he ends up
doing a little bit of anal there in the
woods and there's no bear they had a
bear sound effect but they probably had
sex in three or four different positions
sorry this is an interview right would
you like to go to a barbecue no no I
don't want to go anywhere with these
bunny because I was actually watching a
porno that had a barbecue scene in it
the other day the porns included women
having sex with animals oh my god what
group sex group sex and rape what it's
look this is just office conversation so
I [ __ ] yak you ever seen it can we
actually just talk about the case this
woman took yak [ __ ] in a way that should
be illegal might be illegal you're a
lawyer what do you think well I think
it's actually happening in this room
right now should a woman be able to yak
bang no and I don't want to know about
yak banging I would just like to talk
about the case I'm here to talk about
you ever seen no okay all right oh we
could talk about the case but I just
want to run through I've got a couple
more pornos on the docket to run through
there was some crazy [ __ ] this lady had
sex with an alligator okay their penises
are very tiny I don't want to talk
anymore all right
you look good I don't work is normal
right no give me a fist bump no give me
a kiss mmm
Clarence would also discuss porn that
had guys with huge [ __ ] he specifically
brought up porn star a long dong silver
oh my god what is happening and honestly
as a young boy at the time if you've
never seen a photo of long dong silver
go ahead and look at it what it's not
it's really disturbing we do not condone
that
he also talked about women with big
breasts quote on several occasion Thomas
told me graphically of his own sexual
prowess so he is just full-on disgusting
yeah he's just a [ __ ] piece of
shreditor yeah we're full on predator
disgusting [ __ ] everything you
everything like he's the stereotypical
nightmare [ __ ] [ __ ] boss who's
just gross so misguided to to think I
mean the is no idea how women work
that's what I mean there's always but
these guys always comes they like no
woman in her right mind ever wants to
[ __ ] hear this ever ever yeah but
it's also about power and control and
freaking them out well and we all know
the feeling when you just watched a cool
porn mm-hmm you want to scream it from
rooftops yeah no I know I do
and neither told me she did not want to
have these discussions and especially in
such a graphic wave she'd always tried
to turn the conversation back to work or
even talk about his background a
religion quote my efforts to change the
subject were rarely successful and he
kept asking her out but she was his only
assistant and so was subjected to it
often yeah after a while though it ended
the conversation asking out all of it
and she thought their working
relationship could go back to being
professional
so when Clarence went to the EEOC Anita
had to decide whether or not to go with
him and she decided to working as his
assistant quote the work itself was
interesting I also face the realistic
fact that I had no alternative job the
first months went fine nothing sexual
happened and no date requests and then
in the fall of 1982 it started up again
he started asking why she didn't go out
with him and making comments about how
she looked and whether what she was
wearing made her more or less sexually
attractive quote he began to show real
displeasure in his tone of voice his
demeanor and his continued pressure for
an explanation and is married and he's
married quote one of the oddest episodes
I remember was an occasion in which
Thomas was drinking a coke in his office
he said who has put pubic hair on my
coke he also kept commenting about how
he had a big dick and how good he was
going down on women which I like to call
the trifecta
that's just how are you that's how you
talk to women also he's he's it's
there's there's a there's a there's a
stupidity here like there's like some
some guys know how to talk to him and
some guys don't but this is this is a
combination of not understanding women
at all this is nerd power this yes and
being really [ __ ] Dom on top this
like being completely ignorant about how
women work yeah this is this is I mean
it is he's been in many positions where
his status is so low his status is now
so high that he's yielding it for evil
yeah yeah yeah and and and and asking
her out while doing because he knows
there's no way he can't sense it's like
louis c.k when he when he jerks off when
he closes the door and jerks off in
front of a woman who works for him he's
more turned on by the confusion in her
eyes than anything else but i also don't
understand like the the I mean and I
guess it's just different brains
entirely but the idea that once you're
shot down once you're dead you move away
like you've become a you're you're a sad
relic of a moment past yeah if you keep
goes back to I think it's about power
it's yes it's like a lesser version of
well and now now it sounds like yeah
exactly it's more like he resents her so
now he's like I'll just like him Hail
Mary it all day yeah you know so now I
need is extremely stressed out she's
worried he was gonna fire her demote her
she started looking for another job in
January 1983 but it was hard because she
was worried if he found out he'd take it
out on it and then there was a hiring
freeze put in place by Reagan in
February Anita was so stressed out that
she was hospitalized for five days for
stomach pains and after she was released
she doubled down on finding a new job in
the spring she was offered a job at Oral
Roberts University teaching law and she
took it when she told Clarence he said
she quote would no longer have an excuse
for not going out with him uh
can we talk to you over here Jesus
Christ [ __ ] yeah damn it she said she
still didn't want to go out of them he
offered to take her out to dinner only
as a professional courtesy between boss
and employee is a goodbye dinner oh no
and she reluctantly agreed he told her
for them at the dinner he told her for
the most part he was happy with her work
except for one thing she had done quote
he said that if I ever told anyone about
his behavior toward me it could ruin his
career so he no like yeah that [ __ ]
knows yeah yeah I needed then left in
July and hardly had any contact with
Clarence Thomas after now Clarence his
personal life not going great his
grandfather died in 1983 and he got a
divorce the next year ok 1986 he met
Virginia lamp
she was an Omaha raised Republican who
worked in Congress and then became a
lobbyist where she lobbied against
things like the family medical and Leave
Act which would make large employers
give paid unpaid leave to child to
people who just had a kid so she's
lobbying against yeah maternity allowing
not even maternity leave unpaid
maternity she's lobbying again eight
parents being able to take time all that
without the company paying for it that's
what she's lobbying against so she is in
other words you can't be a parent yes so
she is a stain on humanity right things
Hugh bond the coke can of society thank
you
things were turning around for Clarence
though in 1990 President Bush appointed
him to the US Court of Appeals in
Washington DC now he's never been a
judge and I spent straight to the Court
of Appeals he's never been a judge Court
of Appeals is very powerful yeah yes
that's where he's gone especially the DC
one he's going straight to the [ __ ]
you know high levels of being a judge no
experience whatsoever in 1991 Thurgood
Marshall retired from the Supreme Court
there good was a brave attorney who
played an instrumental role in promoting
racial equality during the civil rights
movement I can't believe he's about I
mean they rise to the Supreme Court is
yeah so fast
for never having been a judge yeah
they're good argued a record-breaking 32
cases before the Supreme Court and 129
of them he won more cases before the
Supreme Court than anyone he was then
put on the Supreme Court by Lyndon
Johnson and became the first black judge
on the court he is one of the most
influential people in shaping social
policies in America and upholding laws
to protect minorities now after stepping
down President George HW Bush thought
it'd be great to replace a man who
fought for minority justice with a man
who loved it right but they were the
same skin color right so yeah 43
year-old Clarence Thomas Bush said
Clarence
was the quote best person in the country
to take Marshalls place on the court
it's so offensive on so many levels that
it's astounding yeah Bush's Attorney
General told him replacing Marshall was
someone who did not hold his views would
make it very difficult and of course
minority groups were furious they hated
his conservative views on civil rights
and thought he was against abortion so
now at this time Supreme Court nominees
were evaluated by committee of the
American Bar Association okay so the bar
would like look at them and evaluate
them and say here's how good there is
about there right and then the Senate
Judiciary Committee would take that into
advisement when they do their hearing
right now Republicans already knew
Clarence Thomas is a [ __ ] pick just a
[ __ ] pick with almost no experience as a
judge and that the bar would give up our
rating over the summer the rumors
swirled around DC about Anita's sexual
harassment by Clarence she was now
professor at the University of Oklahoma
democratic staffers went to her and
asked her to discuss it she did with the
agreement that she would stay anonymous
but Joe Biden was the chairman of the
Judiciary Committee right and his staff
told her if it went into the record her
name would have to be used on September
6th she said she wanted to think about
coming forward the hearing was supposed
to start in four days
okay so the White House and Republican
senators pressured the bar to give
clearance an average quote qualified
rating so they're so the ceiling is
averaged but they're literally like so
worried about how shitty is that right
can we just get it like he doesn't suck
I mean it really does just got like I
mean I'm not it started before that
obviously but like this I mean just what
our system is based on which is just
like nepeta you know what garbage yeah I
mean just non qualifications versus what
bidding will you do well if you don't if
the idea that you're begging a Bar
Association to make a Supreme Court
justice look good if you have a Supreme
Court and you don't again this all this
all comes down to two handshakes right
yeah that's why Trump gets away with
everything because there are no laws
written right tells you what to [ __ ]
right there's no law that says you have
to give your tax records so again this
is a handshake thing like it should be
you have to have a certain amount of
legal experience in court or as a judge
to be on the Supreme Court or else you
get dumb [ __ ]
yeah well it's cool oh yeah it is cool
so at the same time the Republicans so
at the same time is they're pushing the
bar to give them a qualified rating
they're they're painting the bars of
partisan so they're they're working it
from both sides right and Clarence was
given a qualified vote although 212
people voted to voted not qualified and
one refused to vote okay so this is one
of the lowest levels of support a
Supreme Court nominee had ever received
and it was further by I mean it's
terrible that's crazy the Senate
Judiciary Committee yeah he got he got
something he didn't deserve yeah so the
Senate Judiciary Committee hearings
began on September 10 1991 joe biden's
the chairman this was just three years
after biden had been forced to withdraw
from the presidential race for
accusations of plagiarism and what he
considered attacks on his character
okay so a previous Supreme Court nominee
Robert Bork had been rejected and people
saw not much it was because of personal
attacks
so Biden wanted to avoid that again so
he's got people thought that the reason
why Bork was not put on was personal
attack well some people did yeah they
like because of back-alley abortions
well you know you know how they are I
mean yeah so they all were like this man
is a good man yeah so Biden wants to
avoid personal attacks for two reasons
because he felt personally attacked as a
presidential candidate because he
plagiarized a British speech and he said
mate 40 times in it yeah
these are my mates cheers mates Cheers
and the reason is the Bork thing and his
want to go through that again
so he's trying to keep it all about
fitness business now witnesses both for
and against would be heard so Clarence
testified during the hearing Clarence
would not express opinions about
policies or how he would
constitutionally interpret situations
well and at the time people thought he
was being cagey but they didn't realize
that that was just gonna be how he ruled
quiet quiet dumb yeah quiet foolish he
said he had not come up with a position
on Roe versus Wade yeah I mean it's just
[ __ ] truly this should start they
should start they should have like heart
rate monitor that you should be like you
should there should be someone there
who's just like he's lying
yeah like he does remember yeah the
hearings lasted ten days and ended on
September 20th but afterwards Democratic
senators started to worry about Anita's
experiences or more like if they would
become public later and then they would
look bad
didn't-didn't weren't they also like
they were not respectful of her will get
that okay
but this is just they've done the
hearing the hearing is right right now
they it's going to go to a vote to send
it to the Senate floor but now they're
worried like oh well this Anita Hill
stuff is out there right will this make
us look bad when the Rams out the right
way to look at the things yeah sir so
how does this affect my reelection
Senator Edward Kennedy and some others
push Biden to do something about it
so Biden told the
- she can let the committee members know
you know officially by submitting to an
FBI investigation so he's saying if
there's an FBI investigation and it'll
go to the committee and blah blah but
she had both she and Clarence would be
interviewed so she agreed Wow and he was
interviewed by the FBI in Oklahoma three
days later she also sends an affidavit
to the Judiciary Committee okay Clarence
was then interviewed by the FBI at home
and on September 27th the committee met
to vote okay
Anita's charges had still not been made
public so the only people who know about
it are the the judiciary the judiciary
committee and the FBI
all right nobody Biden told Democrats
about her statements just hours before
the why is it being handled so I'm proud
of why is Joe Biden handling this
improperly but I mean is it he what is
his fear his fear is that he's going to
look bat he thinks that it shouldn't be
about personal stuff it should just be
because he literally thinks this doesn't
matter right so they voted the vote was
deadlocked seven seven okay
so Republicans actually do not see the
statement till days after oh wow
what at some point Biden said to his
fellow committee members text 300 300
300 300 300 okay now first Biden told I
had a break or something
Biden told Clarence he would oppose him
but would send his nomination to the
Senate floor okay and it looked like he
would be approved despite Democrats
controlling the Senate so Democrats had
like 57 senators so they're completely
control his hand and there and just the
majority of them are not going to know
about this yeah yeah unless it unless
comes out right but the fbms yeah Biden
also told Clarence he would be treated
fairly if the sexual harassment
allegations were made public
Biden told Tom okay that also sounds
crazy
Senator John Danforth and Clarence's
wife would later write that Biden said
quote I think you're a good man and if
these allegations
I don't think they have merit I will be
your biggest defender so at this at this
he's got receipts yeah so at this at
this vote so there's still they're still
in this
you know they've deadlock 707s I'm still
going all day and then Biden says at the
hearing or whatever it is quote I
believe there are certain things that
are not at issue at all and that is his
character this is about what he believes
and then in what was described as a very
warning tone Biden said quote I know my
colleagues and I urge everyone else to
refrain from personalizing this battle
now he's basically talking to his fellow
Democrats you would literally think that
Joe Biden had done the exact same thing
based on what his behavior his behavior
is now now he made the statement but at
no point had anyone in the hearing said
anything about clearance not being a
good guy that had never come up it was
just all business
so some reporters were there and they're
like what the [ __ ] is this state yeah
they're like wait what see so they start
this out yeah what are you doing so they
said no matter what it shouldn't be
about his character thank you
no there should be bad itch okay so they
started looking into it uh-huh at the
end of the day after an extensive debate
the Judiciary Committee voted 13 1 2
Ford Clarence Thomas's nomination to the
full Senate on September 27 1991 so even
though the Democrats have a woman's
statement an FBI investigation she's
making claims of sexual harassment and
really grotesque
all of the Democrats but one though for
to pass it on pass it on on October 6 an
NPR aired a story breaking down I need
is sexual harassment charges the fact
both had been interviewed by the FBI as
well as an interview with anita herself
and it was backed by witnesses who said
at the time and Nina had told them this
was going on now so intervening Koch
camp yeah that's right
so for me one of the biggest if a woman
comes forward years later
one of the biggest pieces of proof is if
other people say yes she told me at the
time right that to me is just damning
right a news day in your paper also
broke the story on the same day so then
Anita held the press conference and said
she would testify him okay she did this
one day before the final vote was so
thereabouts so in the Senate like the
next shift yeah yeah Biden is now
worried people will be upset about how
he handled things yeah of course I don't
know why I can't imagine what the level
of corruption that I mean truly well is
it corruption or is just a total lack of
human empathy it is moral but it's in
its you you sacrifice those in order to
maintain status quo so that you keep
your job so that you keep your making
money and yeah are still powerful so he
felt he felt like he'd followed the
rules the FBI investigated and that was
given to members of the committee and so
he's like that's always supposed to have
been done but Democrats then postponed
the vote for a week every day this hits
Democrats agreed to have another round
of hearings okay but they gave
concessions to the Republicans and the
way of shaking your head it never it
will never to have 57 they have complete
power yes and they're like well what do
you guys want do you guys what can we do
to get you guys to agree to do this the
new hearings will start in three days
there would be no second committee vote
on Clarence okay so it's automatically
is gonna go to the Senate yes yeah and
there would be a floor vote regardless
of what was learned in the hearing so no
matter what is said in the hearing he's
still gonna get an up-or-down vote
correct furthermore Biden and
Republicans came to the agreement that
the hearings would solely focus on
sexual harassment and avoid stuff like
Clarence's love of porn well out of the
things that creeps me out
hearing him talk about porn and his own
dick where the things that were I would
say we're top-tier
issues so that's left out by that has no
relevance here bearing no he's not gonna
do that when he's on the Supreme Court
of course not you learned a lot just you
put on the robe it's a robe of knowledge
it's a robe of change it's a magic robe
it is bite and then gave clearance the
choice to testify before or after Anita
what why why advantage [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] why all right Anita's gonna
receive an ADA which side of the court
do you want to sit on
I mean you [ __ ] make the call Biden
yeah [ __ ] make the call huh
this guy's a [ __ ] by the redditor
even looking at it from a selfish angle
this is a time for Joe Biden to actually
do it right and get away from like
looking like a [ __ ] yeah so he could
like reset and be like no let's go yeah
we gotta like this we got this guy's a
douchebag I'm not saying we don't vote
him in because he's a douchebag I've
seen because people will know that I
knew he was a douchebag and when it say
it was a douchebag so now we got to say
he's a douchebag so Clarence's chooses
to testify first okay Biden call back to
receive a Biden call that needed to tell
her she asked how the hearing would be
conducted I'm really sloppily I'll be in
charge and I'm uh I'm gonna say here's
the deal a lot Biden said quote well at
this point the only thing we can do is
to conduct an open hearing now Anita
felt like he was blaming her for having
to hold the hearing also he by the way
he pushed all this yes and if you think
back to what she first said she was like
I just don't want anyone to know my name
yeah that's now you're like we're having
a no I mean the level of heightening
this is going through is absurd yeah
Republicans make the movie that's based
on you
so Biden thought that investment FBI
investigation would happen that FBI
investigation the report would then go
to the committee and then no one else
would hear about rats we thought he was
hoping it would all get buried that's
what he thought would happen and now
he's upset with her for coming well
you're happy you've done it again excuse
me is you done it again Anita you really
always
to be at the center of these issues
don't you what Republican congressional
staff we're now looking for affidavits
from Anita's past law students that
would state she'd engaged in unseemly
behaviors they also looked for any info
about psychological conditions that
would make her lie about Clarence Thomas
senator Alan Simpson believed Anita's
claims did not merit serious concern he
was quote angered to the core he's he's
angry well so these angry these guys are
you know they're all over 60 they've
been in power forever they literally
think that this is fine yeah they think
it's fine to do it and they do and they
do feel like like people are invading
their territory that's right they're
very territorial and rude and even when
it's something like this they're like
dicks yep in an interview old and white
yeah it's interesting in an interview he
said quote as a Simpson I am really
getting stuff over the transom about
professor hill I have got statements
from her former law professors
statements from people that know her
statements from Tulsa Oklahoma saying
watch out for this woman yeah watch out
she's really this is 91 and I love
people that act like Republicans changed
at some point yeah like they always
haven't been the most [ __ ] vicious
disgusting pieces of [ __ ] that ever
exists as well as Democrats know well
this isn't painting Democrats good
either well that's their job their job
is to be marginally better yeah so that
we keep believing in heroes the hearings
started three days later networks all
covered it life witnesses who were going
to appear were subpoenaed and sworn in
that included four witnesses who said I
needed told them she was being harassed
while it happened in his opening
statement Biden said this was not a
courtroom and the same rules do not
apply quote we are not here or at least
I am not here to be an advocate for one
side or the other with respect to the
specific allegations which we review yes
I'm not culpable he's literally saying
he's not on a team yeah he's lady saying
that he doesn't care of a conservative
this guy is replacing Thurgood Marshall
I mean Jesus [ __ ] Christ Washington
Post quote some former Senate aides
described Biden as having a
preoccupation with being liked by
members of both parties Biden also said
quote the chair does not have the power
to rule out of order questions that are
not relevant to our proceedings sorry
that's it again the chair does not have
the power to rule out of order questions
that are not relevant to our proceedings
so any question goes basically that's
what he's saying any question goes at
its base can we see your penis Clarence
I mean he's literally saying I can't
there's no overruling of question which
is [ __ ] that's not how they [ __ ]
work especially when you're dealing with
something of sexual like yes nature like
this like if there's something that
makes her uncomfortable she should not
have to talk about it he said both
anything Clarence we're not on trial and
they would not they were not here to
badger I should not feel like she's on
trial no this is she's like a witness
yes so what she's the victim yes
Clarence testified first he said it had
been a hard couple of weeks since he
learned and of course I'm talking about
my dog man I watched this porno the
other day you should have seen this
scoop of porno scoop
yeah they had skeksi scuba sex okay man
we're gonna wrap up the hearing yeah you
know what scuba stands for no
self-contained underwater blowing
apparatus we have to check out yeah
you're not helping your case oh you're
open little Clarence here no I'm gonna
bang it like a gavel watch order ordered
my shorts Klan said he was shocked he
said Anita never said anything to him
and they work together and never brought
it up with her female co-workers which
again even if that was true is not does
not he painted himself as the victim
under attack from the press and these
terrible allegations quote I have never
in all my life felt such hurt such pain
such agony this is where this is this
this this this is what has to go my
family and I
have been done a grave in irreparable
injustice this is not America
this is Kafka esque it's not Kafkaesque
there's nothing about this as Kafka as
right has this relate to copy what well
Dave I feel like I'm turning into a bug
I am NOT going to allow myself to be
further humiliated in order to be
confirmed yesterday I called my mother
she was confined to her bed unable to
work unable to stop crying so I told her
a couple pornos and she went to bed
enough is enough
I will not provide the rope for my own
lynching or further humiliation and
dangerous interesting well I might as
well use that card well well done at the
end but that that really is what that is
what it is it's it's the inability now
to actually accept something as the way
it is and admit fault
yeah rather you undercut victimization
by victimizing yourself yeah and it
works all you do is you just say that
the media's skewed and then you're the
enemy of the media and then that's
probably enough to get you through this
the news cycle yeah I'm a bird needed
given a statement to the FBI or whatever
so Biden then started to say and he did
not want her statement read but instead
wanted to testify herself and say in
person and then senator Orrin Hatch of
Utah cut biting off quote this is the
nomination of a man to become a Justice
of the Supreme Court of United States
hatch was irate Biden asked hatch if he
would yield isn't he's supposed to yield
well hold on hatch has just cut off the
chairman right so there is no yielding
you pound your [ __ ] gavel and say
dude shut your [ __ ] mouth
yeah but he's asking him will you yield
yield he just cut you off [ __ ]
yeah do your goddamn job yeah
so hatch said no let me finish
I'm sorry and then Biden said no I won't
and hatch just said yes you will and
then he finished oh my god Joe quote he
has a right to face the accuser and
everything the accuser says
doesn't I'm going to resign from this
committee today I'm telling you I don't
want to be on it
Republicans were already starting to
completely roll over Joe Biden and
control the hearing right so I needed
testified next but I'll bet you they
liked him
yes which is what Matt's all that
matters I need to give her opening
statement she was very quiet and poised
she says she's black she's 35 years old
the committee is all-male all-white in
all over 60 great visual perfect yeah
Biden set the rules it's like a bunch of
guys you don't want to see naked in the
locker that's how I would describe our
government quote this is Biden it is
appropriate to ask professor Hill
anything any member wishes to ask her to
plumb the depths of her credibility I've
got a member that would like to talk no
Clarence but can you imagine yeah no
reefer yeah he's literally setting her
up to be Savage all right let's stone
the witch I mean it's [ __ ] crazy you
can ask her anything you want yeah yeah
you can ask you test her [ __ ]
credibility yeah this guy is a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] raising an e word layer
later say it was worse than being on
trial because she had absolutely no
legal protections that's crazy
Republicans brutally went after Anita
and Joe did not put up a fight to stop
it Republican said it was weird she
waited eight years to reveal this and
that there were inconsistencies between
her FBI interview and her statements I
mean I mean I mean but she didn't wait
she like was like I don't the I just
want to get away from this interesting
why didn't you come why didn't you at
the time because he wasn't gonna be on
the Supreme Court come on like like a
[ __ ] woman at that time can come
forward this environment doesn't make
you feel comfortable Anita yeah I needa
said quote I may have sure a duty used
poor judgment as far as not reporting
him but she was concerned with her
career and didn't want to burn any
bridges with the boss they questioned
her motives and alluded to the fact that
they had a pile of hideous details of
her private life Michele who did put
that pubic hair upon the can of coke
Eclair and it Clarence's Thomas so
senator Arlen Specter he is from he's a
good guy
easy on the eyes too I don't know what
we're did everything go here what did
you do
Aaron what it's a touch screen touch the
screen touch the screen touch the screen
what I'm just trying to find Gmail dude
I think you signed me I'll touch the
screen okay so a senator I'll inspector
he's from Pennsylvania he accused her of
quote flat-out perjury he's accusing her
of perjury at a non trial another time
he said how is that possible
Oh from the other thing that yeah we are
getting down to [ __ ] business other
side oh my god now we're getting down to
business
unplug the dongle the white thing oh
okay
and then other side it's this I wish you
guys this is why you go to the YouTube
is worth this is worth the price of
admission okay ready yeah
this is our inspector oh you got to turn
the volume on in the bottom there when
you take a look at the transcript Judge
Thomas one you will say some when you
take a look at the transcript and what
will develop this afternoon
very wide out demolition of her
credibility professor Hill you said that
you took it to mean that Judge Thomas
one of the have sex with you but in fact
he never did ask you to have sex correct
no he did not ask me to have sex he did
continually pressure me to go out with
him continually and he would not accept
my explanation as one as being a being
valid you are not now drawing a
conclusion the Judge Thomas sexually
harassed you yes I am drawing that
conclusion that I don't understand
pardon me that I don't understand on
page three it was my opinion at the time
and is now my opinion that Miss Hill's
fantasies about sexual interest in her
were an indication of the fact that she
was having a problem being rejected by
men she was attracted to is flatly he
never asked you to look at pornographic
movies with him with him no he did not
vacation I don't want I'd rather not you
know to determine whether or not the
witness ever saw the FBI report does she
know what was stated by the FBI about
her car well mr. chairman I'm asking her
about what she said to the FBI
I'm just asking it now that you have
read the FBI report you can see that it
contains no reference to any mention of
Judge Thomas's private parts or sexual
prowess or size of his private parts and
his sexual prowess and Long John Silver
that that information was comprehended
within the statement quote Thomas liked
to discuss specific sect Act sex acts
and frequency of sex I did not bring the
information forward to try to establish
a legal claim for sexual harassment I
think we we defer on our interpretation
of what I said what am I missing here
professor the witness speak in her own
words rather than having words put in
her mouth mr. Chairman I object to that
object to that vociferous Lee I'm asking
okay so I'm gonna keep going with this
but but one thing candidate jumps one
thing when when Biden tried to say
something
ireland's all right back at him he just
basically shrugs his shoulders and then
by and that question is horrendous
horrendous and then Biden's not there
for some reason and now he is being
interrupted by Edward Kennedy who was
actually doing his [ __ ] job who was
actually doing his [ __ ] job in
questions here senator Kennedy has
anything to say but him participate in
this hearing oh wait Biden's sitting
right next to him he's [ __ ] doing it
cuz Biden didn't say anything right
goddamnit
uh that is the weakest gap that is like
he gabbled and then laughed that's like
a baby gavel Biden gaveled and then
laugh his gavel is very tiny - ha ha ha
bang bang this proceeding has been
illuminating to tell America what is the
law on sexual harassment that is
something which had not been known I
just would have wished in retrospect
that we had done this earlier and that
this educational process had not come in
this form on a Supreme Court nominee at
at this stage I have wondered about the
quality of those explanations candidly
but there is no description for this
entire proceeding other than a lot of
tragedy what that that is if you watch
that video Joe Biden looks there's two
choices insanely weak or doesn't give a
[ __ ] but there is no other explanation
I think it's a beautiful combination of
both because it always comes down to you
know quote unquote electability how how
well you can work with others but why do
you want to work with others when the
others are just I mean are doing [ __ ]
like are just terrible and that really
is I mean you keep pulling the thread of
how did we end up where we are it's like
it's so evident there but the and the
real thing is that she the idea that she
has to sit there for that like her
internal monologue must just be like oh
my just get through this and it'll end
and time will pass because it's very
clear that she's being scapegoated and
condescended by them saying like this is
like by calling this like a teachable
moment for what sexual harassment is
it's like that's what in that way I came
here no I didn't come here so that I
could be the face of what sexual
harassment what the [ __ ] is like in
white [ __ ]
yeah like nobody knew this is this
wasn't legal like taking her at the end
he's like I think there's been very
educated it's like dude you just you
were a prick yeah
so that's that's our inspector who he's
a Republican moderate from Pennsylvania
and Errol
next up I'm going to play a little bit
of senator Howell Heflin of Alabama good
ready I'll put the thing back in take it
out oh [ __ ]
did that just end it they just turn off
cuz I did that god [ __ ] damn it
this way watch the YouTube get a lot of
behind-the-scenes stuff
so [ __ ] annoying what is the beeping
noises
okay and we are back so who is this is
how how how - holla Heflin he is a
senator from Alabama
okay the progressive state of Alabama it
is very difficult for people to come
forward with these things I've got to
determine what your motivation might be
are you a scorned woman do you have a
militant attitude relative to the area
of civil rights do you have a martyr
complex the issue of fantasy has arisen
are you interested in writing a book it
is appropriate okay that was a Democrat
oh no what the Democrats and the
Republicans each got three people to
pick to ask questions Wow
so out of there seven people one of them
one of them was a cartoonish southern
yeah racist psychopath and I mean the
the way that I mean the level of
thinking is that's astounding are you
even out of touch for an out-of-touch
government but that's me you have a
section are you here to promote some
kind of book about sexual fantasies it's
really it's really it's really crazy so
Wow so that's the hearing that she's
undergoing it's cool though she's got a
lot of allies
as they had set out to do Republicans
then dug up a Texas businessman
part-time professor and Republican named
John Doggett the third who was friends
with Clarence Thomas he had written a
sworn statement claiming Anita
fantasized about him and was
romantically interested in him so what
so there's the case but this is the
delusional angle they're looking for
they want to paint her as delusional
yeah you're right so what it should
never bail out it has nothing to do but
remember Biden said you can undermine
her credibility he allowed this to
happen
this was the delusional angle they're
looking for the Republicans read it into
the record
Anita strongly denied everything Doggett
said quote I did not at any time have a
fantasy about a romance with him but now
Republicans wanted to call Doggett
to testify Biden said quote I mean just
think of the absurdity of what you are
saying yes they want to prove a fantasy
yeah Biden what's sort of lying in the
which in the wardrobe Court finds his
quote there was no right answer Joe I'm
gonna have to text something 203 303 Oh
303 303 which wasn't true because it was
in the violation of the rules that they
had set up so literally calling this guy
forward is in violation of the rules and
Biden says there's no right answer so
who's [ __ ] Tuesday so what's the point
of being there if there's no right
answer what that's like a ref being like
there's no out of bounds and then it's a
hearing Biden put it on Anita and asked
her to decide if docket she'd come
testify rights she gave in and said he
could that's what because if she's if
she says no it that makes it seem like
she's lying it could not be closer to a
Salem witch trial
literally what is your answer if you're
not a witch then why did you float
that's right after the first day
Biden immediately started taking heat
for how poorly he was running the
hearing and how shitty this all looked
and by shitty I mean Anita Hill was now
clearly on trial
Biden quote I don't want to be a judge I
hate this job but all of my colleagues
here are telling everybody how awful the
process is let me be completely blunt
about it
it's like democracy it's a lousy form of
government like demonic cept no one's
figured out another way how what what
kind of ambassador so for race crazy
America to black Yale graduates who came
from poor backgrounds talking about sex
this is a media dream after the first
day a local New York news channel called
it quote x-rated an extraordinary news
Cruz spoke to people on the street every
interview I watched men said clearance
was being attacked and did nothing wrong
and almost all women said she was
telling the truth
so when Clarence came back senator Orrin
Hatch Utah held up a copy of the novel
The Exorcist
he better be promoting it and this
happened what's happening you said you
never did it this book no ya never read
this book no The Exorcist exhort Oh
senator never see the movie I've seen
only the scene with the bad flapping you
said you never did say this who has put
pubic hair on my coke
you never did talk to her about long
dong silver can we just say that this is
the greatest thing about this hearing is
that a bunch of the guys had to say long
dong silver over
it also it was like when Clinton got the
I was like the penis like this is so
clogged we read the Judiciary Committee
calls long dog silver have you read this
book no The Exorcist
no senator never seen a movie I've seen
only the scene with the bad flapping you
said you never did say this who has put
pubic hair on my coke
you never did talk to her about long
dong silver I submit no no no why would
I start over I mean no one likes to feel
stuck with more head back especially by
your cloud it's a problem but the IBM
cloud is the most open and secure public
cloud for business you can manage all
your apps and data anywhere without
getting in your way
sorry that's it never eat this book no
acne Exorcist
no senator never see the movie I've seen
only the scene with the bad flapping you
said you never did say this who has put
pubic hair on my coke
you never did talk to her about long
dong silver I submit those things were
found on page 70 of this particular
version of The Exorcist Oh Burke's shied
serán their side Sharon in a guarded
tone she described an encounter between
the senator and the director dennings
had remarked him in passing said Sharon
that there appeared to be quote an alien
pubic hair floating around in my gym
unquote and she would have us believe
that you were saying these things
because you wanted to date her what what
what what what I mean what proof what
proof that's what I had that's my issue
with the Bible it's just like yeah if
someone wrote it so it's what evidence
is that what evidence is there
that's literally he's a tone of
somebody's making a point with zero
point he's saying because there was a
pubic hair in a gin in the exorcism
there she lifted that plot and also how
would anybody hit on a woman so weekly
like that's all he says he reads from
The Exorcist yeah now being a legal
mastermind hatch also suggested Anita
got the term long dong silver from a
sexual harassment lawsuit that had
happened in Kansas quote this is a
public opinion that's available in any
law library I'm sure it's available
there in the law school at Oklahoma so
because someone had brought up long dong
slower who I'm sorry is a the biggest
name in porn a since it's in another
case that means she
stole it anita was never brought back to
dispute these accusations
again that was Biden's choice right on
the third day of hearings news lawyers
said she passed a lie-detector test so
now that made Republicans mad right
so already furious senator Alan Simpson
read a statement from a federal
prosecutor quote if a person suffers
from a delusional disorder he or she may
pass a polygraph test what about
evidence Simpson was calling an ADA Hill
delusional senator Simpson did not
mention that the federal prosecutor who
made the statement was part of Claire's
defense team Clarence laid it really
laid it on to the committee for his
final statement quote as far as I'm
concerned it is a high-tech lynching for
uppity blacks who in any way designed to
think for themselves to do for
themselves to have different ideas and
it is a message that unless you couch
out to an old order this is what will
happen to you you will be lynched
destroyed caricatured by a committee of
the US Senate rather than hung from a
tree it's effective yes he's the deal at
one of the very last witnesses was
docket long Doggett so remember that guy
that shouldn't be testifying
all right the Texas guy he gave a
rambling argumentative testimony and he
said and Nita was quote somewhat
unstable and had a problem with men
especially John Doggett quote miss
Hill's fantasies about my sexual
interest in her were an indication of
the fact that she was having a problem
with being rejected by men she was
attracted to of course Biden told
Doggett it sounded like a quote true
leap of faith or ego and then Democratic
senator Howard Metzenbaum of Ohio
started asking Doggett about unsworn
allegations that he had harassed the
19-yard woman that he worked with
okay so counter saran this entire thing
is about undermining the credibility of
Anita Hill so now this Democratic
senator is doing his job which is
undermining the credibility of this guy
buying the iDEN cut him off he said
there was no evidence that Doggett had
done anything wrong and apologized to
him
four witnesses testified what a colossal
[ __ ] up and [ __ ] you
yeah four witnesses testified for Anita
two said she had told him about
Clarence's sexual harassment when it was
happening sixteen people testified that
clearance was awesome there was one more
witness Angela Wright
she was then an editor at the Charlotte
Observer and she had worked with
Clarence at the EEOC she said he had
asked about the size of her breasts and
repeatedly asked her to go on dates
Clarence once showed to her apartment
uninvited Wright had been deposed by
democratic staffers and was now waiting
in another room to testify Joe Biden no
did not call her to testify he said
there wasn't enough time what later
other Democrats would say they doubted
her credibility but who's covering for
who there well still orrin hatch is
reading from The Exorcist
yes credibility doesn't seem to be on
trial here the press knew about Wright
and Clarence was asked about her but
when I was over she was forgotten and
not part of the equation because she
didn't testify yeah instead they have a
literal [ __ ] lunatic testifying and
and made Anita agree to that right and
the right wasn't the only one Rose
Jourdain worked at the EEOC and said she
could verify Wright's account of sexual
harassment Sakaki Hartnett also worked
at the EEOC she wrote to the committee
quote if you were young black female and
reasonably attractive you knew full well
you were being inspected and auditioned
as a female by Thomas neither were
called to testify and those were both
Joe Biden's decisions again he said not
enough time the final day of the hearing
had been set aside for panel's of pro
Clarence Thomas witnesses plus did it
matter Joe had already promised a floor
vote two days later the Senate voted 52
to 48 to confirm a judge Clarence Thomas
to the Supreme Court two Republicans
voted no since there are 57 Democrats in
the Senate he could have easily been
defeated but 11 Democrats voted for
Clarence Thomas in 1992 four women were
elected to the Senate to bring the
to six out of a hundred six percent the
media then declared it year of the woman
that year Joe was clearly beginning to
understand people didn't think his
actions as chairman where were [ __ ] he
told The Washington Post quote I erred
in not attacking the attackers more
frequently and consistently there still
has not been a black female judge on the
Supreme Court I can think he wanted to
put on there luckily Joe Biden told an
audience in South Carolina five days ago
that he would put a black woman on the
highest court in 2004 Arlen Specter was
primary by more conservative Republican
and he barely won and many Democrats
supported him against their own
Democratic nominee Specter won the race
against the Democrat and was back in the
Senate and in 2009 Specter switched to
the democratic party political quote and
the democratic party's courtship of
Arlen Specter no one may have played a
bigger role than Vice President Joe
Biden Joe apparently thought a lot of
the man who said horrific things to
Anita Hill political quote joe said at a
fundraiser in houston that he's been
trying to come inspector that he's
really a Democrat for over two decades
calling himself a close friend maybe the
closest friend Specter had in the Senate
Biden said he doesn't expect his former
colleague to vote lockstep with the
Democrats
Joe quote but the point what a huge I
mean that that truly says so much about
what is wrong yes yeah the idea that you
view it is I mean it's just I mean
there's been a lot of talk about Biden
accepting really horrific people
particularly racists yeah but here's a
guy who who raped a woman over the coals
who was sexually harassed and that's his
bro yeah that's his bro right Joe quote
but the point is that Arlen is now freed
up to vote in any way that he doesn't
have to worry about that angering his
leadership it's a tough spot to be in he
has been in the last little while so I
think it's a good thing it's good for my
friend Ireland it's also good for our
party but it's even better for our
country on the real critical issues
health care and others I think you are
going to see it's going to make a
difference it didn't what he did was he
voted
he voted with Republicans mostly and
then when he was up for election he
voted for Democrats in 2010 inspectors
switch to the Democratic Party had
switch to the Democrat and the
Pennsylvania Democratic Party and
divorced him was 77 percent of the votes
the now the Pennsylvania Democrats are
fully behind them Joe Biden campaign for
specter against the other Democratic
candidate who was actually a Democrat
and the other guy won the primary and
went on to win the race against the
Republican and became a senator specters
career was over he died in 2012 on
February 9th 2016 the New York Times
wrote quote breaking a decade-long
silence Justice Clarence Thomas on
Monday suddenly started asking questions
from the Supreme Court bench he had not
asked a question in ten years this was a
record and it had been 45 years since
another Justice had gone just one term
without asking a question no one is ever
gonna break his record well he also I
believe at the time was like getting
heat for that record and so it was like
publicly known that he had not spoken in
that long so he didn't break the record
because he finally had questions yeah he
broke the record because he was finally
being questioned the belief that Joe
Biden [ __ ] over Anita Hill stayed with
him in November 2017 at Glamour's women
of the year event he said quote so sorry
that she had to go through what she went
through he emphasized he Frick he
emphasized he believed her and voted
against Clarence he and he then he told
The Huffington Post quote what I do feel
badly about is the bad taste that got
left in the mouth of some of the people
around me to Hill and maybe even Anita
and maybe even Anita know maybe the next
month he was being interviewed by Teen
Vogue and he said he regretted not being
able to quote tone down the attacks by
Republicans he also said I could have
done as a chairman he didn't have the
power to do so
which he did which he completely did
yeah quote as much as I mean that sounds
crazy as a chairman I had no power we
literally saw him interrupt a guy and
then shrug his [ __ ] shoulders the
Chairman as a king I'm not allowed to
decide what the monarchy I mean it
[ __ ] Kennedy had to [ __ ] jump in
at one point they're being such [ __ ]
and bud just sat there quietly
he quote as much as I tried to intervene
I did not have the power to gavel them
out of order I tried to be like a judge
and only allow a question that would be
revelant to ass by the way he was like a
judge like Clarence Thomas Joe then said
quote I owe her an apology this is
recent
he said he regretted it again in March
2019 an event in New York but those who
knew he actually had a lot of influence
over how the hiring was run weren't
buying it
that same month on March 20th 2019 the
New York Times headline the quote
Clarence Thomas breaks three-year
silence at the Supreme Court pushed by
people like Senator Barbara Boxer to
apologize Joe called Anita in the middle
of April 2019 I need to listened and
asked him not to tell the press he had
called God and he did a week later Biden
announced he was running for president
and his campaign told the press he
called Anita and shared quote his regret
for what she endured so he did it again
yeah she asked him not to I need it any
did Anita then I had to talk to the
press and said it was not an apology
quote I cannot be satisfied by simply
saying I'm sorry for what happened to
you I will be satisfied when I know
there is a real change and real
accountability and real purpose the next
day Biden went on the view a horrific
show with four famous rich women
discussing what's best for America Joy
Behar said to Biden he should tell Annie
to quote I'm sorry for the way I treated
you not the way you were treated and
bonded Biden responded quote I'm sorry
for the way she got treated if you go
back to what I said and didn't say I
don't think I treated her badly he
repeated he did everything his power to
stop things during the hearing a couple
days later Biden Biden moved a little
bit he told Good Morning America's he's
getting so much yeah yeah until a Good
Morning America quote I believed her
from the very beginning but I was
chairman she did not get a fair hearing
she did not get treated well that's my
responsibility as the committee chairman
I take responsibility that she did not
get treated well I take responsibility
for that Biden then said he'd apologized
to Anita and the host said she did not
believe it was an apology
today professor Anita Hill yeah she's
doing well over the year she's Mountain
TV program she's written articles she's
been a voice on sexual harassment race
she is currently a professor at Brandis
University Clarence Thomas is on the
Supreme Court doing his best to reverse
everything Thurgood Marshall did he has
a disturbing lack of curiosity for a
Supreme Court justice Joe Biden is one
of the leading candidates / president
for president even though he is a
clearly diminishing mind in archaic
views of society there was a running
joke in the Anita Hill household every
time the doorbell rang they would say it
was that Joe Biden coming to apologize
for years the the damn like because
Clarence Thomas is not not only he's
such a damaging figure like his wife is
monster damaging and they just have so
much access now like it again I mean it
is we it's it's just like when your team
drafts a player you're not gonna know
how good they are for a few years when
you make these decisions and you do
these things you're lucky because you
have some time until there's gonna be
the ripple effect when you actually see
what they do but the last thing you can
do is since you can't since we can't
until we have fiery torches get Clarence
Thomas off of the Supreme Court or and
the Supreme Court all we can do is be
pissed about it but if you have the
gatekeeper her still relevant still
important still potentially going to be
the guy that you're saying is going to
stop Republicans it just feels like not
only a fool's errand but the second trip
yeah that's pretty bad he's it's not
just what happened Anita Hill he did
this with busing yeah he did this with
crime he did this with now
he did this with the Iraq war he corn
pop corn pop his mind is diminished he
is really bad yeah and the Anita Hill
thing the fact that he was picked to be
vice president which was a which was
really a by Obama a nod to racists that
he's not gonna be that bad but that said
all this emotion Joe Biden should not
have been anywhere near the White House
he's not a good person he this what he
did here is astounding it's disgusting
and really no woman should support him
ever
I bet Anita Hill isn't I mean she might
vote for Trump right choices for her boy
man that is terrible it's terrible it
really is a and it's a very you know
these times are so stressful because
everybody feels so strongly and
impassioned in making things normal
again or feel good again or feel at
least regular not assaultive but at the
end of the day like you know I just I
just don't know how many and I mean I
thought this one we had bushes and we
had Clintons it's just like you know how
many times are you gonna let the same
this same cult because that's really all
it is doesn't it it transcends gender
transcends race at transection transcend
sexuality it's a cult about elitism and
money and money and I mean they just
want to hold their money they want to
hold their power and they are trying to
get through this time right now and
trying to batten down the hatch so hold
on and in May 2016 I was on a podcast
called Toph up with Will Anderson with
Jen Kirkman and I had been really sort
of watching the polls and everything and
my opinion was that Hilary would lose to
Trump and I broke down why and I broke
down the states and I wrote down why she
was this those states and I was right
and that was in May 2016
and now people are online telling me
that I'm wrong and that Joe Biden will
win yeah oh well so I just want to put
out there you were wrong about Hillary
Clinton I was right Michael Moore was
right
several of us were right why don't you
[ __ ] ask us what we think or instead
of you being wrong twice I think
truthfully that what people think is
that people think that Trump is an
anomaly that 2016 was just like the
Halley's Comet of Elections and what I
think I don't think enough people look
at it the way you're saying which is
that it's not the person it's the policy
yes the policies are like it doesn't
matter if Joe Biden is friends with
Obama if Joe Biden wears sunglasses if
you call him Uncle Joe at the end of the
day what is being rejected by this class
of people who's totally forgotten by the
elites is that they're going to reject
everything yes they're going to reject
everything unless they feel like it's
actually gonna make a difference yes and
you're just not you just don't hear
enough from the establishment that is
going to make people want to feel like
any candidate that supports NAFTA or
have supported NAFTA is going to lose
the election to trump yeah straight up
you're not gonna win Michigan you're not
gonna win any of those states it use if
you put poor the candidate that
supported NAFTA you are done well I
think I think I mean Biden yeah all
right well anyway we got politically big
babies
cuz I'm gonna hear about it yeah you are
[Music]
crazy all right
yeah yeah America why are you applauding
I just gotta do something all right we
sign cars yeah we signed something
recently